anthony blinken and defense secretary
lloyd austin are holding a briefing
after talks with president vladimir
zelinsky in kiev let's listen in for the
ukrainian government
and for the ukrainian people
this was in our judgment an important
moment uh to be there
uh an important moment for for ukraine
uh for the war
uh an important moment to have
face-to-face conversations in detail
uh about the
extraordinary uh
support that we've provided security
economic humanitarian
as well as the massive pressure that
we've been exerting on russia
and then to talk in detail about how we
carry that forward
across all of those fronts
uh i would say that um without putting
words in his mouth uh president
zielenski
expressed deep appreciation
for president biden's leadership and for
the incredible generosity and support of
the american people
in turn
we expressed
deep admiration
for his leadership
for the extraordinary courage
of ukrainians in standing up to
and pushing back this russian aggression
um
part of our commitment going forward
involves a number of things that i was
able to share with president zolensky
yesterday including the return of
american diplomats to ukraine starting
next week including
president biden's attempt to nominate a
new ambassador to ukraine ambassador
bridget brink currently
an ambassador someone i've served with
for a long time deeply experienced in
the region he'll be a very strong
representative for the united states
in ukraine
we
had an opportunity as well to
talk about
where this goes from here
with the success that ukraine has had
it's also true that russia continues to
try to brutalize parts of the country
and the death and destruction that we
continue to see is horrific
but ukrainians are standing up they're
standing strong and they're doing that
with the support that we have
coordinated uh from literally around the
world
um
the strategy that we've put in place
massive support for ukraine
massive pressure against russia
solidarity uh with more than 30
countries uh engaged in these efforts
is having real results
and we're seeing that when it comes to
russia's war aims
russia is failing
ukraine is succeeding
russia has sought as its principal aim
to totally subjugate ukraine to take
away its sovereignty to take away its
independence
that has failed
it sought to assert the power of its
military and its economy we of course
are seeing just the opposite a military
that is dramatically underperforming an
economy as a result of sanctions as a
result of a mass exodus from russia
that is in shambles
and it sought to divide the west and
nato
of course we're seeing exactly the
opposite an alliance more divided than
i've ever seen it and indeed uh new
countries uh considering
uh applying for membership
the bottom line uh is this we don't know
how the rest of this war will unfold
but we do know
that a sovereign independent ukraine
will be around a lot longer than
vladimir putin's on the scene
and our support for ukraine going
forward will continue it will continue
until we see final success
secretary
good morning and uh first of all let me
echo what secretary blinken has said
uh in terms of the characterization of
our meeting
i think it was very uh productive uh
meeting very engaging uh session
uh and we were
very happy to have that opportunity so
during the meeting we expressed our
deepest condolences to the president
uh for the loss of so many civilians and
of course
the loss of those uh courageous troops
uh that have done just a magnificent job
of uh pushing back russian forces
we also expressed our admiration for
their professionalism and for their
commitment to defend their their
democracy just it's been extraordinary
to watch and i think everyone would
agree with me there
i agree with secretary blinken that the
president did express
uh his
deep appreciation along with the
minister of defense and the chief of
defense
their deep appreciation for what the
american people
have continued to do
to ensure that we get them
as much assistance
as possible as quickly as possible
so
uh our focus uh in the meeting was to uh
talk about those things that would
enable us to win the current fight and
also build for tomorrow
and and uh again a very productive
discussion we talked about security
force assistance
and we talked about training and we also
talked about uh
the the
key things that we're going to discuss
in the session that i'll conduct
tomorrow at ramstein with a number of
ministers of defense and chiefs of
defense this session is focused on
doing things to generate additional
capability
capacity for the ukrainian forces and so
it's a great opportunity uh to get a
good update from the child from the
minister of defense and from the
president on the things that they are
focused on the things that they need
that will enable us to have a more
productive discussion with the chads and
ministers of defense tomorrow
secretary houston secretary blinken i'm
just wondering if you can tell us what
you saw uh during your visit to keeve on
your journey
on the way to kyiv and what you saw in
the city were you able to speak to any
ukrainians outside the government and
what did they tell you if so and then
for either of you
do you see a scenario where the where
international support enables uh ukraine
to avoid losing this war to russia but
isn't able to fully expel russian forces
or reclaim its victory and how would you
think about
such a scenario thanks
i'm happy to start in terms of what we
saw we uh
we took a train into into kiev
from southwestern poland so
didn't see a lot except looking at the
train windows on our way in and in kiev
itself we went right to the presidential
palace we spent about three hours with
president zlensky with his senior team
that was the entire focus of our visit
we wanted to focus uh on the work that
needed to be done in uh looking at the
game plan that we have how we're moving
forward across all of these different
lines of effort so that was the entire
focus there wasn't much of an
opportunity to to talk to
average ukrainians we certainly saw
people on the streets in kiev uh
evidence of the fact that the battle for
keep was was one and there is what looks
uh you know from the surface at least to
be a normal life in key but that's in
stark uh contrast to what's going on in
other parts of ukraine in the south and
the east where the russian brutality uh
is doing horrific things to people every
single day in terms of uh
wars won and lost again i come back to
the proposition that uh in terms of
russia's war aims russia has already
failed and ukraine has already succeeded
because the principal aim that president
putin brought to this in his own words
was to fully subsume ukraine back into
russia to take away its sovereignty and
independence and that has not happened
and clearly will not happen
where the the contours of the war goes
from here how much death and destruction
continues obviously that's a deep
concern
we want to do everything we can to help
the ukrainians bring this to an end on
the best possible terms as quickly as
possible much of the work that we're
doing is enabling them to strengthen
their hand both on the battlefield right
now but also eventually at a negotiation
if there is one i agree with secretary
blink and we were focused on uh the
conduct of the meeting and engaging the
the senior leadership so we didn't get a
chance to uh to do any walkabouts or
engage uh
civilians or citizens on the street
uh on the way in we did look like things
were beginning to come back uh to normal
uh it was uh easter day so in in kiev so
certainly a number of people would have
been at home and not on the street
in terms of uh our their ability to win
uh the first step in winning is
believing that you can win and so they
believe that we can win
we believe that they we can win they can
win if they have the right
equipment the right support and we're
going to do everything we can continue
to do everything we can to ensure that
that gets you so we're uh we're
engaged with the chad engaged with the
minister of defense and as this fight
evolves
uh you know their needs will change and
so as those needs change we'd like to be
one step ahead uh but uh we're gonna be
responsive to what the chad and the mod
uh believe that they need
secretary austin i have a question about
aid deliveries
how are you tracking the
stingers and the javelins and the the
strategy those sensitive weapons we're
seeing more and more imagery of those
weapons falling into the hands of
russian-backed forces in donbass do you
have a plan to track those weapons and
in terms of humanitarian aid secretary
blinken
there's an article in the boston globe
today quoting a usaid official saying
that the billion dollars in aid passed
by congress has not even been
transferred to usaid accounts and that
much of the aid that's supposed to be
going into ukraine has not been
delivered calling it a critical
strategic failure how do you plan to fix
this problem
the first part of the question jen
thanks thanks for that question in terms
of our ability to track the weapons that
are going in as you know we don't have
any forces on the ground so that's uh
that is difficult for us to do
we did have a very uh uh good discussion
with uh both the chad and and the
president minister of defense on a
necessity to make sure that uh that
those weapons are tracked and as best
possible to make sure that they're
protected from falling in the hands of
adversaries now when you're in a fight
as you know uh if uh if a specific
battle is lost then you have less
control over that or your ability to
control items but
they are focused on this issue and they
know we are concerned about it and uh
we'll continue to to engage
and jennifer in terms of humanitarian
assistance hundreds of millions of
dollars of assistance has already gotten
in not only to ukraine but to
surrounding countries that are caring
for ukrainians who've been displaced who
are refugees uh literally every day as
we speak eight is going in
this is eight
uh if you're here in a few hours
this won't be here it's gonna be on a
plane on its way uh or some other means
on its way to uh to ukraine and then it
is dispersed uh throughout the country
we've had detailed conversations with
our ukrainian partners about making sure
that once the assistance gets into
ukraine it then is dispersed as
secretary of defense was saying about
the uh the weaponry in an effective way
and if their uh bottlenecks there are
challenges there we're working through
them but what i'm seeing at least is
that aid is getting here and other
distribution points it's getting out the
door incredibly quickly again this place
is going to look different five or six
hours from now than it does right now
well
uh thank you so much uh secretary austin
uh you mentioned you know keeping
abreast with what the ukrainians need
we've seen uh you know certainly some
155 millimeter howitzers and other
things being processed through here what
did president zielinski say he needs
next and uh for secretary blinken uh i
understand you may have spoken with um
the u.n secretary general about his
upcoming visit what is what is the
strategy for engaging uh for his
engagement or for world engagement with
moscow and with kiev uh to see it into
this thing
as you've heard us talk uh
or say in the past recent past the
nature of the fight uh has evolved uh
the terrain that they're now focused on
is a different type of terrain
so they need uh long-range fires uh
you've heard them express a need for
tanks
and we're doing everything that we can
to get them uh the types of support the
types of
artillery and munitions that will be
effective in this stage of the fight
and so we'll get a chance to we've done
a lot as you know you've seen
that what we've done here in recent past
with the 800 recent 800 million dollar
authorization provided by the president
allows us to provide five battalions of
155 howitzers uh hundreds of thousands
of uh
of uh rounds of uni of uh artillery
and so we're also engaging our our uh
colleagues in in other countries for the
same type of capability and we see
indications early on that they're gonna
they're gonna be uh many countries are
gonna come forward and provide
additional uh
munitions and howitzers so we're going
to push as hard as we can as quickly as
we can to get them what they need this
will be a great topic of
conversation for our meeting tomorrow as
we go down to ramstein
and um in terms of the secretary journal
i spoke to the union secretary general
on friday and he is heading to moscow
early this week and our expectation is
that he's going to carry a very strong
and clear message to vladimir putin
which is the need to end this war now
the need for a ceasefire the need for
humanitarian corridors uh for aid to get
in for people to be able to get out uh
the need for russia to stop its
brutalization of ukraine it's a clear
direct message that he should be
carrying on behalf of virtually the
entire uh international community
john
are you defining america's goals for
success any differently in ukraine uh
now than you were at the beginning of
this war and if so what are those goals
today
i'll i'll just start and i'll let the
secretary of state give his thoughts but
i think
and he's already kind of
indicated the first piece of this we
want to see
uh ukraine remain a sovereign
country a democratic country able to
protect its uh uh its sovereign
territory we want to see russia
weakened to the degree that it can't uh
do the kinds of things that uh it has
done in invading ukraine so it has
already lost a lot of military
capability and a lot of a lot of its
troops quite frankly and we want to see
them not have the capability to very
quickly reproduce that capability we
want to see the international community
more united
especially nato and we're seeing that
and that's based upon the hard work of
number one president biden but also our
allies and partners who have willingly
leaned into this with us as we've
imposed sanctions as we've uh moved very
rapidly to demonstrate that we're going
to defend every inch of nato
really nothing to add i think the
secretary said it very well
take a final question matt thanks mr
secretary were you able um to offer uh
president zielinski any um uh idea about
the timing of the reopening of the
embassy in kiev and not simply the
return of diplomats to to
levive and for both of you
president zielinski when he kind of uh
leaked
the that you guys were going there on
saturday
said please don't come with empty hands
you obviously didn't go with empty hands
but did you get the sense that he is
satisfied with with what it was that you
did
bring uh matt in terms of the the
embassy
we will have american diplomats back in
ukraine starting next week
they'll then start the process of
looking at how we actually reopen the
embassy itself in kiev i think that will
take place over
a couple of weeks would be my
expectation uh we're doing it
deliberately uh we're doing it carefully
we're doing it with the security of our
personnel foremost in mind but we're
doing it um and with regard to
president zelinski again
without wanting to characterize him too
much i i can just repeat what i said
earlier he expressed to both of us
deep and repeated appreciation
both for president biden's leadership
but also for the generosity of the
american people i think he said lloyd uh
that uh the united states has been
ukraine's strongest supporter something
that uh that they won't forget uh and uh
look we never we never come empty-handed
because this is as the secretary of
defense said this has been an ongoing
process where we have been
from before day one because remember
the initial drawdowns that president
biden ordered go back to last labor day
months before the aggression we wanted
to make sure that if russia pursued the
aggression the ukrainians had in hand
the tools they needed to stop it to push
it back and that's exactly what happened
thanks to their courage to their
commitment but also thanks to the
equipment that they had in hand from
before the war started they were able to
do that but as the secretary said this
has been evolving and so the nature of
our assistance and the assistance we're
getting from others has been evolving
and as you would expect he did express
express gratitude to uh to the american
people and our allies and partners for
what they're they've done from the very
beginning and continue to do
but he's in a fight and so while he's
grateful for all the things that we're
doing
he's also focused on what he thinks
he'll need next in order to be
successful and again they have the
mindset that they want to win we have
the mindset that we want to help them
win and we are going to do that now in
terms of
specific types of things that we were
able to discuss and and
and
kind of lay out you know we
reminded them that uh
thursday the pres president biden signed
a uh you know a drawdown and uh on
saturday uh howard's were showing up
from that drawdown package that is uh
unimaginable speed uh and uh it's due to
the hard work of all the men and women
who are working day out uh day in and
day out to uh to do the kinds of things
that they're doing but we're going to
remain focused on giving him what he
needs to be successful in the future and
that's what you you'd expect you'd
expect for him to say thanks but uh
and he's really grateful but you know
let's focus on what needs to be done
we'll get a chance to talk some more
about that in our meeting with the
charge tomorrow and i look forward to
that meeting thank you thanks everyone
okay that was u.s secretaries of state
and defense speaking in poland following
a high-level visit to kiev and a meeting
with president vladimir zelinsky the
pair arrived in the capitol via train
they said and spent three hours with
zielinski and his team at the
presidential palace the u.s has pledged
700 million dollars in funding for
military aid and they were standing in
front of supplies which will head to
ukraine
uh anthony blinken revealed u.s
diplomats will return to ukraine next
week and they plan to open the embassy
in kyiv in the coming weeks he went on
to say that russia is failing and
ukraine is succeeding in this war and
america's support will continue until it
sees complete success lord austin will
be conducting a session with defence
ministers tomorrow in germany